[Music]
dude I'm better get up because I will
call that stupid
Colton years up for hometowns as the
drama between everyone hits an all-time
high it's said that some girls want to
get to the end of this by tearing other
people down I thought a sh and I were
friends and I hate confrontation but at
this point I just don't even care
anymore several issues were brought to a
head during Monday night's episode of
The Bachelor which had the women
confronting one another and Colton
trying to get to the bottom of it all on
whether certain women were there for the
right reasons I'm hearing two completely
different things
from women that I feel like I trust amid
the chaos in the house
Colton surprised Hannah B with an early
at meet the parents that ended up in a
goodbye I know that I shocked him
and that there is no explanation that I
could give her other than for me it just
didn't feel good
[Music]
I think the hardest part about all this
is knowing that she was falling over
there and Heather made a surprisingly
sweet exit on her own accord
during the awkward group date where
Cassie and kirpa went head-to-head
people still are here for the right
reasons or that they're not ready why
would you go spend your time talking to
Colton about me I think he needs to know
all the know but Ally because you're
just I never with him I knew today
wasn't gonna be easy with Kaylin
crashing the date to reassure Colton his
instincts about the women are correct
he gave Cassie the fourth and final rose
as he joins Hannah G Taoiseach and
Kaylin in their hometowns it's not about
no she said she said thing it's about my
instinct and what my guts telling me et
caught up with the show's host Chris
Harrison ahead of the episode where he
dished on the drama
how did Colton not stop and go Kenya
just whispering I guess right can I get
names it is funny to me that he never
said for that hey Sydney or Jamie or
whoever who are you talking about
right like help a brother out yeah
you're leaving so it doesn't matter yeah
burn Rome down let me know what's going
on yeah and he never asked for that
which is really odd to me that would be
the first question Greg's who but you
know where is it sour grapes that the
girls are just bitter that they're
leaving I always wonder that that has to
be a good one thing I will say and this
happens for the bachelor and it happens
for the women you don't know what's
going on you don't know what's going on
with Kaylin or Cassie or Hannah B or
Hannah G you don't know what's going on
with their relationships and you kind of
have to understand that when you watch
the show later and a lot of times when
you come back to the women tell they're
like oh I see it now
yeah I didn't get to see that date now I
see the love I see the affection and I
realize my relationship I thought was
good it was nothing compared to theirs
so it does help them to watch the show
back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]